[Music]
you're listening to
inside of you with michael rosenbaum uh
hi ryan how are you hi michael i'm okay
how are you it's always good seeing your
face it's nice to see your face as well
i hope everyone's having a wonderful
week and thank you for listening to the
podcast thank you for continuing to
listen if you're just here for emil
hirsch i hope you stick around and say
hey you know what this ain't half [ __ ]
and uh you want to stick around a little
longer because that would make me really
feel happy and good about myself and
increase self-esteem and
half [ __ ] and that's still running
around in my brain you like half [ __ ]
i don't i'm trying to make sense of it
uh we'll get into everything after the
show
we'll get pretty much right into emil
hirsch now uh just letting you know
i have a show this coming saturday july
31st
at 2 p.m and 6 p.m two shows uh go to
stageit.com
and type in sunspin that's my band uh
you can also go to sunspin.com
and get tickets please come uh check it
out i think you'll enjoy it we'll play
some covers play some originals our cds
out we've got merge tons of [ __ ] uh if
you're liking the show
i'd love for you to follow us the
handles are at inside of you
podcast on instagram and facebook
at insideyoupod on the twitter uh you
could
subscribe to us on youtube you can watch
these videos or you can listen to them
on
apple stitcher and other ways but please
uh
please subscribe write a review really
helps the show the little show that
could
and uh we appreciate that and uh join
the lovely patreon patreon helps the
podcast in more ways than one so thanks
for
being a part of patreon and i love all
my patrons
and right now this guy was pretty damn
interesting
uh yeah you know he's just he's had a
really cool career i mean
into the wild and working with tarantino
and working with a lot of big actors i
mean
he's done it uh lords of dog town yeah i
mean he's done some pretty diverse roles
yeah i would say uh this is a really
this is a really good conversation and i
was excited to
uh hang out with him for an hour so
let's get inside of emil hirsch
it's my point of view you're
listening to inside of you with michael
rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
i took my friend to play pickleball the
other day
she didn't have that much experience and
she dived
for the ball dive on concrete
no no she hit the chain link fence but
like
like superman like horizontal like hit
it but then
bounced off the fence and slammed onto
the concrete and
broke her hand while you were playing
with her yeah and
like i was i wasn't playing with her she
was playing my friend kenny
and then i look over and like everyone
stops the doing and starts walking
towards her and she had broken this bone
right here which is your index finger
but in the hand
card and uh yeah so it was like hours in
the er
it was crazy i don't want to tell
anybody i broke my hand playing
pickleball
i don't know but is that what i'm seeing
like i went on your instagram and i saw
it was like you're
joining the first pro am celebrity
tournament in november is that what that
is for pickleball
yeah which is funny because i go over to
randall's house to just play a game
and he's like films me and just says
that i didn't even
like i didn't even i'd never even heard
of it before that now randall is randall
the director of uh midnight in the
switchgrass
yeah randall's the director of midnight
in the switchgrass who i've known
for you know he produced lone survivor
and then he produced uh another film i
did and so i've
known him for a while wow he's a
character though he loves playing
pickleball
he like he's super competitive about it
like he hires
pros to like come to his house and train
him and like
like be brutal on him and like brutal
drills like i'll come over and he's like
dinking with some pro like wait wait
wait wait
wait your friend randall who directed
midnight in the switchgrass
he he grunts after he hits he's one of
those guys
that when you watch tennis and you're
seeing the go
he runs on every serve it's not just
like
it's like a oh
like it's like it's like the serve is
like some sort of release every time
it's like
i always find that so funny i mean i
played tennis my whole life and i would
suck in grunts i'm not grunting i'm not
making any noises
maybe i would have been a better tennis
player if i would have grunted more i
don't know would you ever tell
guys were you like could you be a little
quiet like could you try to not
moan as much on the court yeah i'm
uncomfortable yeah it's really like it's
kind of like
affecting my play yeah it's loud and
it's distracting
so stop it i dude look man you've been
in everything i mean i look at this list
of movies and i'm
incredibly jealous i'm like into the
wild girl next door lords of dog town
lone survivor comeback trail
once upon a time in hollywood milk
killer joe it's like you've done all
these movies
i think if i did one of these movies i'd
be freaking thrilled i think my parents
would be very happy that i did something
that accomplished something
and now midnight in the switchgrass so
you play this detective and i saw the
trailer for it and i want to watch it
because this looks intense as [ __ ] it's
got megan fox
and uh robert de niro it's bruce willis
bruce willis well
he looked like robert de niro they're
all dudes you know
what was it what was it like on that
film and what's the movie about so it's
it's like a serial killer kind of movie
where i play the
the kind of the good uh the good guy cop
you know just an honest dude a real
religious guy
depends on his wife to give him that
real uh
spiritual sustenance from the brutal job
and he's
trying to crack cases that are just
really hard to crack and so it's
sort of a film of uh you know like kind
of tracking the killer tracking the cops
trying to get the killer
they sort of converge at a certain point
now i know how much research you do in
on on rolls and stuff did you did you do
a lot of research on i mean
have you already done research another
well i feel like
because i did so much on loan survivor
to play a navy seal
in a certain way a lot of the law
enforcement roles i've done afterwards i
definitely feel like i
pulled from a lot of that research i did
just because i did a lot on that
one and so there's something about
that that you kind of don't forget a lot
of it yeah just the general vibe
it's interesting i was talking about
this the other day where
because of the way like netflix and all
these
these true crime documentaries work you
know like
people have done a lot of research and
they don't even realize it like
we've watched most average viewers at
least if you watch what's in the
zeitgeist
there's so many of these true crime
things you know
that you're a bit more exposed you've
heard a lot of homicide detectives talk
in interviews more than you think yeah i
love seeing lucas haas because he
he's a great guy and you're a good
friend of his i know him for years as
well
and it's good to see him he's such a
good actor and you don't see him enough
you just don't for some reason and i
wish he would i know he does a lot of
indies and things like that
but seeing him in a row like this i'm
just like just that dirty kind of
dark role and i don't know where it goes
i know they're trying to you know you
see the trail and you're thinking one
thing i know it's going to be something
else
but it's exciting to see that i'm sure
it's exciting to you as a friend of his
yeah i mean i've been friends with lucas
for ever
uh we worked together on alpha dog uh
you know
16 17 years 17 years ago
and i was a big fan of lucas as just a
kid i mean i remember i used to rent his
movies at the video store when i was a
kid
and uh you know lady and white witness
and all these
all these movies i mean he was like it's
like a big deal
even just as a kid um so
to get a work with him and be friends
with him uh after all these years was
pretty cool and
i felt like his role was so
he was it's so interesting because he
has such like a baby face and this like
kind of innocence
to him and seeing that kind of used for
the darkness
of the part i thought was a
was it just like aside from being
extremely talented and great in the
movie it's also just really smart
casting too
yeah you know what i mean that's a big
you know it's
so important that parts are well cast
and i felt like that was a surprising
surprisingly good choice for that
particular part for him
you know yeah you know i've seen a lot
of interviews with you
and uh all the people that you've worked
with and
what comes into my mind is do you ever
get starstruck i see you like
there's a shot on the comeback trail
with like de niro behind the camera
giving you the offline you know
off-camera lines to you
and i'm thinking that's got to be the
most surreal thing i know you're
probably used to it
well do you get used to it and do you
ever feel like god i sucked in front of
one of the greats i'm sucking
i'm sucking i can't get it i'm getting
nervous i don't really i don't think i
get that used to it
i remember like my first day on comeback
trail with de niro i was already really
prepared because it was
a scene with just lots of lines just
rattling him off non-stop but i was
still so nervous
and then he and then we started the
scene and he was just like came
guns blazing like just
every word on point like just so good
i was like oh my god like and i remember
i like i dropped a cue and he was like
oh then you say that and i was just like
oh my god
like i forgot a line
with de niro like like literally like
the shame
and i remember i was like oh my god like
just
like like i was like dude i'm like 36
like this dude's older than me like i
remember i went back to my trailer and i
learned my lines
like so well because i was like there's
no way i'm ever going to let him like
like remind me of my cue
ever again so you just looked at he goes
yeah you missed the
line about this and then you say that in
there and i was like oh my oh my god
like it was such a i don't know i mean
he's so good it's crazy he's he's really
good
well i ready and yeah go ahead and even
even with like tarantino i was like
i don't think i've ever been more
nervous around anybody
been around clinton what's his
personality like i mean is it like you
see on the daily
oh that's not we're gonna do this he's
basically quentin i mean he's always
quit
but i was just i was such
like a following devoted fan of his
forever that i'm just i was just like
it was like having like a cult leader
around or something i was just like oh
you know i don't know it's like i grew
up watching his movies
so much that you know it's like i just
can't i i tried to treat him like
regular or just be calm around but i
just i couldn't you couldn't you were
all other people i think could but i
just
i couldn't do it what kind of direction
did he give you i mean do you remember
specific direction or like the way he
was
acting that was it was it was he very
helpful did he know exactly what he
wanted
yeah i mean i remember early on we did a
read-through
and i was kind of playing j sebring
more as like what i would see in little
video clips of him where he's sort of
like a kind of a calm
kind of like laconic dower guy
and i sort of so i sort of did that in
the read-through
uh where it was like brad and leo and
burt reynolds at the time it was like
all these crazy awesome margo and dakota
fanning
um and he called me afterwards
and he was like you know he basically
gently told me that i was on the wrong
path so he basically was like i'm
this guy this isn't a biopic he's like
you can have
fun with the lines this is this is like
this is tarantino dialogue you can
you can i'm giving you permission to be
more flamboyant
he was like jay isn't gay he's not gay
but he's a flamboyant guy
he's like you can bring that side of
yourself um
he's like i'm giving you permission to
have fun to enjoy it to be more
flamboyant
and as soon as he told me that he really
kind of i was like
i went back and i read the scenes the
way that i had played them
in the read-through and i was like oh my
god
like what did i do because i i totally
as soon as he told me that
i completely understood what he wanted
and what he meant and in
every line made sense that way but i was
trying to like kind of fit a square peg
into a round hole
because i was taking these preconceived
notions of what i thought j
sebring was exactly like based off some
video interview
and you know sometimes in order to kind
of get to the truth of a scene the way
it's written
you need to like not adhere perfectly to
your
preconceived notions of what it should
be yeah well a lot of times you hear
these horror stories and it's it's
happened
it hasn't happened to me but it's
happened to some friends who are
famous that they'll do a table read and
they just for some reason the producer
and the director is like
no this guy's [ __ ] completely off and
they just fire him
i mean you know it was nice enough for
him to call you be like no you could do
this i just know what you're doing
you're playing it more like a biopic you
need to play it
like have fun man i remember when i
first got that call
i i was like oh my gosh i like literally
was driving and i like
pulled the car over i was like
like waiting for the bomb to draw and i
was like
okay okay it was pretty funny though
have you ever been
fired by a job he's definitely the one
that i would i just
i couldn't i just couldn't treat him
like a normal dude i was just too
starstruck
have you ever been fired off a job no
wow i have not while i was shooting i
think i've lost
parts that they had like given me and
then i like they
took them away that's happened for sure
though oh god
you said in an interview that sometimes
you feel like you've forgotten it all
when you get on set like you question
everything and then it takes you
like a day or two how does that work
after all these movies you just feel
like sometimes you go back on set and
you're like
do i know how to do this explain that
yeah it's weird it's almost like an
irrational
fear or something that
basically before almost every single job
i do
if there's like more than a week between
the job or something
there's a point where i'm like man i
don't know if i can do this
i don't it's and it's like there's a
part of me i'm like well
you've been through this before and you
do know how to do this and you'll get on
set and you'll do it and that's like
your thing and but like
the belief that i can't do it
is is like real i mean it's like there
do you feel
nerves is it nerves do you feel these
like intense like anxiety or what is
that
super intense anxiety and also
like more than just a feeling like the
actual like the thinking of like i
i don't think i can do it like i don't i
don't really think
i'm up to this it's a weird thing and
you know how crazy it is right you know
how
you're logically you're a smart guy so
you're thinking i've done this i've
killed it i know what i'm doing so why
am i feeling like this
i know it's the weirdest thing i don't
know i've i
i've talked to a couple actors that kind
of they're like
yeah you have that too you know it's
kind of a weird thing
i don't know it's probably just sort of
nerves or just sitting around with too
much to
to think about um i don't know though
i almost wonder if like when you stop
feeling if i were to stop feeling that
way i almost wonder if
like something would get stale or if i
wouldn't be as excited or
you know because you only get that way
if you care like if you don't care at
all
you're not going to be like i don't know
if i can do this you're going to be like
i don't care if i can do this
you know what i mean
inside of you is brought to you by geico
i don't know about you guys but i'm lazy
as hell
ryan you lazy as hell no well i'm lazy
at some things
like how about this i like convenience
ah
i like being convenienced who doesn't
well
i don't like going to the grocery store
so i have this company that i could shop
online and they deliver it yeah sure
you could do the same thing with geico
except it's not for groceries
it's for insurance like for instance
homeowners insurance
renters insurance along with your auto
policy you could bundle those they have
bundling policies guys with geico
you can make your life so much easier
and you could save a ton
all you have to do is this you go to
geico.com you get a quote
and you see how much you can save it's
geico easy
visit geico.com today that's geico.com
inside of you is brought to you by
truebill
ryan do you know why free trials renew
without your consent
so they can get you they're trying to
trap you yeah so let's not let greedy
corporations pocket our money
download truebill right now to take
control of your subscriptions
truebill is the new app that helps you
identify and stop
paying for subscriptions you don't need
or
want or simply forgot about on average
people save up to seven hundred and
twenty dollars a year with truebill
because companies make subscriptions
hard to freaking cancel truebill makes
it incredibly simple
just link your accounts and true bill
will cancel your unwanted subscriptions
in one tap
and your true bill concierge is there
when you need them to cancel unwanted
subscriptions
so you don't have to is your ex still
using your netflix
do you really need all those streaming
services now that you're back
in the office from forgotten free trials
to automatic renewals
when big companies keep charging you
true bill is your secret weapon to save
you money
on subscriptions that you just don't
need so don't fall for subscription
scams
start canceling today at truebill.com
inside truebill.com
inside it could save you hundreds a year
truebill.com slash
inside i mean when when you're doing
lone survivor
this story always baffles me i've never
heard a story like this where
this guy actor you goes to a party
you see pete peterburg you know peter
and
you know you want to get lone survivor
this story i think is fascinating
yeah yeah tell us the story because i
don't think a lot of people have heard
this
so i had heard pete was making one
survivor and i would occasionally see
him in the gym
in venice beach um
because we both lived and he lived in
like westward or santa monica but he
liked to work out at gold's gym
and i would see him in there so we
mentioned that he was
making one survivor and so i saw him at
like
i don't know some sort of party and he
was
with a friend and i went up to him i was
like what's up with lone survivor man
and he was like you know how there's
like
nfl movie and like you know it's like
you can't play
like a linebacker and it was like i mean
it was like a really like
down-down nerd you know what i mean i
was like i was like oh okay
okay and i just i don't know i just i i
had read the book and i really was moved
by the book
so i wrote pete um a letter being like
you know
how i felt about the project what you
know how i wanted to be a part of it
and my agent was like i don't know he's
he
he just doesn't see for this and i was
like just just
come on and i wrote i think i wrote him
a second letter wow and at one point he
wrote back to me
like show up at gold's
early tomorrow
and i was like what time and he didn't
write back
and i was like oh man this is one of
those like psychological
psychops experiments or something so i
woke up at
4 00 am because gold's gym opened at
like 6 00 or 5 30
and i was like waiting at the gym as it
opened
and this guy tr goodman who was the like
coach trainer guy
shows up and said what are you doing
here and i was like oh well pete told me
to show up here earlier
started laughing he said come back in
like two hours so i came back
and uh were you pumping by the way were
you pumping up
well or you're just waiting for him like
holy [ __ ] i want what what the hell is
this about
i was just like ready to go you know and
and
basically they put me through this
really hard workout that day
gold's gym um
i i want to separate a really hard
workout for an actor from like
navy seal training it's really not
comparable in any way
at all but for me it was like probably
the hardest i'd ever had to work out
and so they didn't give me the part pete
just said you have to show up here every
day
for like the next few months i'm not
giving you the role because i genuinely
don't know if you can do it and i'm not
going to disrespect
the seals and this guy's family by
giving an actor that's like
a punk if he can't do it because i was a
little bit
you know i wasn't really in great shape
um
and so it was every day from
six to usually six a.m to like eleven oh
god or eleven thirty i would finish and
it would be usually like 90 minutes of
weightlifting
and then it would be two back-to-back
hours of cardio
so i would either do like an hour on the
bike and then an hour jog or like
an hour on the ergometer which is the
arm machine an
hour of that is insane by the way did he
have somebody like watching you and
doing these workouts with you or
did he leave and just assume you were
doing this when i would do
the weights i was training with the
with the workout crew so it would the
guys that i was training with and a
couple of girls
most of the guys were like major league
baseball players or hockey players that
were off season that were like trying to
stay
in top level shape it was it was really
like a performance
weight training camp it's called pro
camp for a reason
in in venice and uh
i definitely got in the best shape of my
life and in a certain certain points
it was really hard because every day for
so many hours just on my body and
i was like man this is intense and they
even for what pro camp was they made
sure that what i was doing was always
harder than what everybody else was
doing so
we would be doing like okay let's say we
did 90 minutes of weights
they would be like okay you have to do
jumping jacks between your weight sets
so
while everyone else is waiting at the
machine to do it you have to do the
jumping jacks for like
pop squats or like side step you know it
was stuff like that it would
constantly be like ratcheting it up and
uh
and i just sort of just was super
focused and determined and i really
wanted to be there and i wanted to be in
the film
and i got into really good shape and uh
it was funny i didn't know this at the
time
but apparently tr told peter berg
after the fact that i had trained harder
than anyone he'd ever had other than
chris
chellios who was an nhs stanley cup
champion
hall of famer chicago blackhawks thought
i know shelly
[ __ ] best yeah apparently tr who's
like the man he told pete that he never
told me that but
he told pete did you call your agents
and say
so i don't have this role but i have to
work out for the next couple of months
to find out if i
do so you can't really work out a deal
because there's no deal to be had until
pete
gives the word one yeah i mean it was
kind of nerve-wracking in that way
because
if i would if i would like lag
on any of the workouts or if i was doing
um
you know like an interval like long
intervals
or circuits we did a lot of circuits if
i would fall behind
they would be like oh we're going to
tell pete he's not going to hire me no
they did not
they said no and they were serious
really like hardcore like that
you know and he's like pete has told me
to give an honest assessment and if you
fail at this i will not like you are not
gonna do this
i mean were you pissed were you like did
you kind of laugh it off or were you
like
[ __ ] oh i mean i was frustrated i mean i
remember one day
i was on the leg press and
they just kept stacking more 45s
on the leg press to where like i
genuinely couldn't do it
like it was like it was crazy
and at one point i was like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] like i stood up and like
chewed these guys out and like walked
off and all the like hockey guys were
like oh my gosh
this is so but like i think that they
were
trying to like break you yeah i mean i
think that that's we're so
he's like all right now that we've got
this anger let's channel it you know i
mean it was like
all this sensei uh you know like karate
kid kind of stuff with with tr
and when was the moment that he called
you but he said you got it
how'd that happen do you remember that
it might have almost been like a text
message like
you're in or something like that you
know it was like
and i was it was funny because the
reason why i don't
remember that moment was because after
like
three months of that i was in such good
shape that like i knew there was no way
i wasn't gonna get it right like i was
actually
confident at that part in the beginning
i wasn't confident
because i wasn't in shape at all i was
really like oh
i don't know but by the end i was like
man i can run
like seven miles like fast you know
you know and you had navy seals like
breathing down your neck
on set and things like that that's what
i hear like you were it was just
very intense shooting was it always
intense yeah it was always pretty
intense yeah i mean
um the seals were they really wanted
their story to be told in the right way
and marcus luttrell had
a big responsibility to get that story
right
for all the families so he took that
seriously
wow how much weight did you lose playing
christopher mccandless how much weight
did how much did you weigh so for into
the wilds
i remember i was 156
when i got the part because i hadn't
gotten on a scale in
ages and i remember i got on the scale
and i was like
dad like my scale's broken i need will
you get me a new one
and he's like oh i'll pick you up one at
walmart and then he like brought me a
new scale and i got on and i was like
this scale is broken too man i think my
dad was like
maybe the scale's not broken and i was
like oh it's
oh oh um so
i remember sean shawn wanted me to get
pretty lean because the real chris was
he was pretty lean even before he
had that big weight loss so uh
i lost probably went down to like 133
from 156 just to get into like the
shape for the movie for the normal parts
and then we shot like half the movie
and i was doing a lot of like running
every day and eating healthy and
you know spin and uh
and then there was like a two week
shutdown
in the middle of the shoot and i had
gone down probably to like 124
and then i had two weeks so i was doing
like two spin classes a day
and like eating like the bare minimum
and at one point
dude two spring classes a day on no food
is so
hard like i don't know if you've ever
done that probably haven't but no it's
like
psychologically like it is so like it's
me you're just like oh it like
hurts it doesn't physically hurt but
like it psychically hurts
and i remember i would like sit up
in those like two or three weeks and
like my vision would go totally orange
for like 15 seconds like
literally blind i remember i texted my
doctor i was like hey doc
i'm going blind when i'm sitting up like
every time and he was like oh you need
to
take some salt because that's like low
blood pressure so i did that
and then that kind of went away so then
i went down to like 115
pounds and we went to alaska yeah and
then i was there
and we shot the good news was is we shot
most of those scenes
in like six day period so i was like
crazy skinny
but like on like the third or fourth day
like i could like
feel like my heart like palpitating
like i could actually feel it like boom
and i was like oh [ __ ]
so i told him i was like we gotta finish
these scenes because i can like feel i
don't have much time to like keep
shooting this
this is like probably not safe that is
insane
i mean you know i watched these shows
you ever watched like alone the shows
alone where people
heard of it it's funny my friend one of
my friends from childhood
his brother is like on alone right now
really
yeah well they dropped them off and it's
real i mean they're alone
and whoever lasts the longest is the
winner
and it's it's crazy the [ __ ] that they
do
but they have doctors that come in every
i don't know when it is every week to
just check on them check their vitals
now someone who is 159 or whatever
you were in the beginning to drop down
to 115 were they always monitoring you
were they always making sure hey he's
okay i mean because that's that
sounds pretty dangerous i had a really
talented doctor
um that the insurance company had me
work with and he was really experienced
and he was one of the main doctors on
biggest loser so i was kind of
consulting with him but then at a
certain point i did
i you know the last few pounds i think
that
i wasn't like approved to lose you know
what i mean
but i'm also you know i'm like five six
and a half
five seven i mean i would actually
i'd still say that like i've seen
way more extra i mean i don't look at
that as like a weight loss
kind of i mean it's a weight loss role
but i don't look at it like that i look
at like what
jared leto did in dallas fires club or
what bale did in the machinist or even
what matt damon did
encourage under fire i actually think
those dudes lost like more weight
you know i think it feels like i lost
a lot lot more weight because of the
environment in the
within the story too and the characters
starving and all that so it like it
really seems like it
but if you actually were to compare my
like height and body mass and everything
to some of those other ones like i think
there's actors that have lost more for
sure
for sure wow uh you know it says
christopher mcanlis wanted to explore
the unexplored and discover life without
responsibility possessions people money
but in doing so he went to his death
from into the wild
um i mean do you ever consider because i
i know i do it probably crosses
everyone's mind i mean because you know
how hollywood can be and how crazy it
could be and
uh was there an essence of you in
when you played the role where you felt
like there is something that makes you
want to get away sometimes it makes you
want to just disconnect from everything
maybe not in an extreme level but
something you just like break away and
just like
not have to deal with all the [ __ ]
and just kind of live your life and see
what it's really about
there's definitely an appeal that i
think
struck a chord with me and so many other
people to the story
the idea the call of the wild or the
beckoning of the open road that we all
have
the ability to sort of leave the past
behind and move
forward and have a new fresh start
um and a new kind of a new horizon at
every day i mean i know in one of the
letters
mccandless wrote the old man ron were
you saying like you know the core of
man's spirit comes from new experiences
and there really is something to that
you know what those new experiences are
or the way that you have them kind of
varies but there's
you know part of what keeps you alive is
is that kind of adventure whatever those
adventures are
um and i really related in a great way
especially at that age you know i
i just turned 21 when we shot that movie
so i was like so just it was like just a
big adventure to me
um you know i think
part of appreciating that story
uh it's also sort of like appreciating
some of the wisdom that mccandless got
but like hard
earned was you know and that like i i
sound like the
the older guy now saying that but um
you know like
was it cool that he didn't contact his
parents
no and i would almost argue that like he
would have thought that
by the end you know and and
happiness is real when shared you know
like the fact that he wrote that
that's like a reckoning with what he's
saying that's
that's a slight rebuttal to a lot of
what he was doing
so that isn't um that's not like uh
oh you just gotta go into the wild and
live there alone that's that's that's a
different meaning
you know uh he didn't write like
happiness is so great because i'm alone
right now
you know since he realized how much
saying happiness is only real when
shared and you're alone like clearly
you're you know not ex doing exactly
what you think you should be doing in
that
in that way in that moment so i feel
like
that story and the character you know
ideally you would get a
appreciation for adventure and a love of
nature
and the idea of the core of man
spirit comes from new experiences but
you can also take like
the lessons that he learned without
having to pay that kind of high price
yeah um in terms of you know having a
guide
uh that embraces company and uh
socialness and and um you know doesn't
just give you that sense of adventure
with like a complete rejection
of uh like sharing of happiness with
others
and it took him a lot to get to that
point because he had such an unhappy
childhood in a lot of ways you know he
had
he had a really hard time with his
parents
inside of you is brought to you by
hellofresh i'll tell you what what if
you can make
delicious healthy meals and you can put
to put them together and it's already
put together for you all you have to do
is
sort of cook them yeah so someone says
oh i want to make
chicken cacciatore sounds complicated
well i wouldn't even know how to do it
you look at a recipe book and then you
gotta go buy all these different things
and you got to put them together and
what if all these things were right
there for you that's what hello fresh is
with hellofresh
you get fresh pre-measured ingredients
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered
right to your door skip trips to the
grocery store and count on hellofresh to
make
home cooking easy fun and affordable and
that's why it's america's
number one meal hellofresh offers 50
menu and market items each week
including ready to eat
salads sandwiches and soups try hello
fresh's quick and easy meals 15 to 20
minute dinners breakfast on the go and
more easy options perfect for your busy
lifestyle i love hello fresh because
they make it easier i feel like i'm
uh doing something i can actually make a
dinner but it's all right there for me
it's healthy it's ready it's delicious
hello fresh
there's not much more to say other than
get hello fresh make your life easier
uh enjoy your life just go to
hellofresh.com iou14
and use code iou14
for up to 14 free meals
plus free shipping it doesn't get
greater than that folks
listen again go to hellofresh.com
iou14 use the code iou14 for up to 14
free meals plus free shipping
it doesn't get better than that
hellofresh try them
you'll love them inside of you is
brought to you in no small part
thanks to our lovely supporters over on
patreon folks if you enjoy the podcast
you love talking about episodes you want
to stay involved in the inside of your
community
i highly suggest that you check it out
check out patreon
it's quickly turned into one of the
coolest things i've been a part of over
the last year and that's for sure
patreon.com inside of you is where you
go
if you want to get early access to
episode content check out the patreon
if you want to interact with other fans
of the show check out the patreon
if you want to get exclusive access to
have your questions asked during the
show
check out the patreon heck if you just
love what we do and uh
you like ryan and you want to just keep
this train a rolling
check out the patreon it really helps
the podcast more than you could possibly
know
it doesn't take much to get involved and
i'm there all the time chatting with
folks and putting together live hangouts
i literally would not be able to do this
without you guys so
thank you again and again to get more
involved in the community today head
over to patreon.com
inside of you that's patreon.com
inside of you see you there soon
how was your childhood was it pretty
good i mean were your parents really
supportive and always
you know i was you know i was very lucky
that i had
super supportive loving parents um
you know i realize now more than ever at
being a parent myself how important that
is so i'm i'm
very grateful that i had parents that
kind of put the attention that they did
into me
your mom was a visual artist and pop-up
books designer
yeah do you know how much that would
help my dumb ass
growing up in school well
you know she's just my mom is just an
artist she's just always
drawing or painting or making something
i mean she's just
she's always been like that i think uh
she's very industrious
you know she never stops doing that um
i definitely get some of that from her
in the way that i am i'm always
i'm i try to always be doing something
creative in some way or doing something
it doesn't have to be creative
can you be alone can you go on
excursions for a week at a time alone
with no one and just
can you do that do you like doing that
no i can't do that
you you don't like being alone i like
being alone
sometimes but that was one of the big
things on into the wild um that i had to
do
is i had to learn like i had to like go
on hikes by myself
for long periods of time and like just
learn how to deal with that
you know what i mean because it was so
foreign to me
i'm i'm a pretty social creature yeah
i'm a creature i'm a social creature um
i gotta talk about this because you know
i'm a horror movie fanatic if you looked
in here you'd see all these horror movie
posters i just love heart but i know you
work with william freaking
and you know i mean the exorcist and
he's done a ton of other [ __ ]
amazing [ __ ] but i mean did you
when you worked with him first of all
was he a dick or was he really cool and
open it just seems like he'd be so
intense
i remember the first time i met billy i
like drove up to his
cool mansion in the hills it's like this
gothic mansion and i go in
and it's literally like satan's office
like
a massive office filled with books but
it's like darkly lit with all this dark
gothic art on the walls and he like
was sitting like it felt like by a
fireplace and like a super high-backed
chair like you're
i mean i was like whoa this is so crazy
i mean i definitely had vibes of like
this guy directed the exorcist and then
he said something that was kind of like
spooky and supernatural and i was like
oh [ __ ]
like this guy's intense did you ever ask
him any questions about the exorcist
like any
insight that's about the exorcist all
the time and he didn't care
he loved talking about it i mean it was
like he clearly had such an you know
i think that movie it's just like
imagine making a movie that
affected the world that much i mean
it was at the time it was biggest box
office movie of all time
yeah and it was considered like one of
the most
disturbing movies ever i mean it was
like
he was saying that there was like they
showed it everywhere in the world
he said something about there was
something like in like south
america like showing like like
uh natives to those areas that had like
come down from the mountains that had
never even seen movies before
like they didn't even know what a movie
was and they were just watching the
movie and like
they didn't even know how to pay for the
movie he said they were throwing change
at the screen
i mean like just what like wild stuff
and i feel like
billy is like he really like it almost
makes it scarier because when he talks
about it he's like he's a kind of
he really believes a lot of it you know
well it's basically the exercise was
based on a real book i mean it was based
on a yeah it happened to a boy i think
bieber like
he like it's almost scarier too when he
talks about it because you're like oh
wow
he's not like some skeptic he's like and
it's all real
you know what i mean it's like was there
any like one story that you asked him
about that
is interesting that he really didn't
talk about a lot or the public doesn't
know just about the exorcist or anything
that he shot
because i'm sure you you pegged him for
something he's like well you're dealing
with a young girl here who's
x amount of years old and playing this
role and doing i mean what did you talk
about
one thing he said that if he if he would
if he were to go back that he might have
not he didn't say he wouldn't he said he
might have not
made that film with uh
with that actress he's like you know
it's like a crazy role and a young
actress and
he said he might have not done that no i
thought that was interesting
so we might have regrets well you know i
mean i think it was probably a pretty
i mean i'm sure it was a tough shoot and
then just kind of being associated with
that role i don't know but i
honestly i don't know though because he
didn't say he wouldn't either
he said he might have not right right
you know you're banned i love that you
play music i play music i have an album
out i l
i listen to i listen to hysterical
kindness hysterical kindness simple
things
yeah yeah and i think people usually go
oh another actor with a band and then
you listen to and you're like
this i really really enjoyed
and you're the lead singer right yeah so
hysterical kindness i did based off this
movie all nighter where i play a
bluegrass singer
and they gave me these two guys that
knew the producers that were real
musicians
so when we were making the movie i was
like well let's let's like we
recorded a bob singer cover song of
night moves and it sounded really cool
so we were like my friend i played it
for
he was like why don't you guys just
write some originals and see what comes
of that
so i started writing a bunch of songs
with these guys
and we just started recording them like
in their closet
literally and uh and we made this whole
album it's like 13 tracks
so then fast forward a couple of years
later
i want to make more music and they just
the guys they're doing other stuff
they're making money in other ways
all that they don't have the time so i
met this french
music producer named machu karate who
was kind of a mutual friend of mine my
buddy matt smiley is
his girlfriend justine wachsberger like
they were
friends for a while and matthew had been
the uh
the editor of premier magazine france
for a while so he kind of had like a
film base
but he wanted he had done dj work and he
wanted to be a music producer so
we ended up making like one song
together
and i liked the way it sounded so we
kind of kept going and then we we made
one song that was like oh
this is kind of a vibe and we ended up
in the last two years we put out two
albums and
um you know we kind of just it's a it's
a different vibe than hysterical
kindness which is more bluegrass
uh the stuff i make with the frenchman
is more um like an 80s kind of
electronic
pop kind of
can i play one song you care no not at
all
there's this one song she calls you oh
yeah
all right so here it is this is she
calls you hysterical kindness
[Music]
i love i love that song i love so what
what's next you just released something
in
in march yeah this uh the second
hirsch album denialism uh we put out
we got a pretty cool write-up in
american songwriter that was like the
first kind of piece of anything that was
written about it which is pretty cool
will you play out anywhere eventually
i would love to i think it'd be cool i
mean i'd probably need to take like six
months of voice lessons
so that i'm not doing 50 takes in a
booth and auto tuning and melody my
voice you know i might have a nice
tone to my voice but i have no like
craft in terms of singing
well i love the voice it's unique and it
just it just sounds cool it just sounds
it sounds it's got the indie cool feel
that could easily
pop out to uh mainstream i don't know i
i dug i truly dug it or i wouldn't have
played it or even brought it up i would
have been like [ __ ]
yes my friend uh this is it this is
called [ __ ] talking with
emily hurt emily with emil hirsch have
you ever heard that but
has anyone ever called you emily or all
my life or a mile
that's like practically my nickname do
you just hate it or you just use
elementary school
no not at all oatmeal a man which is a
meal
or a meal for his mama this kid sinclair
in fifth grade was like
he's like literally like dribbling a
basketball and he goes a meal for his
mama
i was like you're going places kid
you're going places all right this is
called [ __ ] talking with emil hirsch
this is
rapid fire this is my these are my
patrons so you just rapid fire answer
them
okay raj during the pandemic what's the
longest stretch of time you went wearing
the same clothes
three days good answer kelly asks what's
your favorite film in terms of the story
itself
probably um on the waterfront
really that's a good one yeah it's a
good one i'm not saying it's not
uh steph a uh working on alpha dog what
was it like uh
it was such an intense film i have to
imagine it was not easy to uh to make
rest in peace anton it was a lot of fun
uh great young cast uh everyone was
friendly and had a good time
and nick cassavetes was rocking and yeah
we had it i mean we had a lot of fun
little lisa what values are most
important to you
i think family is really important and
uh
you know perseverance maya p what's the
most challenging character you've
portrayed and why
i think overall um chris mccandless and
into the wild because it had
so many different types of challenges
physical and mental
and i was you know still kind of
learning and growing as an actor when i
did it so it was like there was a lot to
kind of
adapt to as i went and ray h which is
part of the question how much
research did you do on chris mccandless
before starting
into the wild definitely as much as i
could do i talked to a lot of his
friends and family and parents and
sister and
um he read about him and watched
everything i could and
uh just tried to absorb as much as i
i could that would hopefully come
through in some way
awesome midnight in the switch grass is
is it
out now it comes out on uh the 23rd
freaking watch this midnight in the
switchgrass watch the trailer you'll
want to watch
it's intense as [ __ ] uh emile hirsch
this has been awesome man i feel like i
know you're already and
uh i love talking to you yeah this has
been a blast thank you for having me on
all right buddy i hope to see you soon
we'll play some pickleball yeah watch
your hands though okay
i will i'll wear a glove bye-bye see you
buddy
another uh fun episode i hope you liked
emil hirsch
ryan did you enjoy this one was it a fun
edit i did uh
yeah i mean he's an interesting guy like
you know it's funny when you see these
people that you've known about
for a long time and then just sort of
see them sit down and be
people for an hour yeah it's always
gonna open up and you don't know how
they're gonna be they're gonna be like a
character are they gonna be like this
he's a he's pretty much a dude yeah he
just comes across as a nice guy
oh yeah you know so i really enjoyed it
i really enjoyed him being on the
podcast
um letting you know that uh patreon if
you want to join the lovely patreon to
help support the podcast in other ways
go to patreon
p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash inside of
you
there's different tiers you get merch
from me and notes from me
and there's a bunch of stuff go to
patreon.com inside of you
also my band is playing this weekend
sunspin
you can go to sunspin.com for tickets
merch zooms
booking the band anything you want and
uh inside of you
uh the podcast you could go to the
inside of you online store and get uh
i mean anything from inside of you mugs
and t-shirts and uh
two uh lex luthor pictures and uh funko
pops and
smallville lunch boxes bunch of great
stuff on there so if you
if you want to do that um i will also be
at um lexington
comic-con september 9th through the 12th
actually dragoncon before that september
4th
in atlanta that weekend tom welling and
i will be together then
lexington september 9th and then west
virginia september 24th
uh very excited about these very excited
about the cons um
hopefully um i'll see you there we
occasionally do this
smallville nights thing so you better
get your tickets
and uh ryan you get anything going on uh
not at the moment
i went to the gym i went to the dentist
today you did i just went to the dentist
too what do the dentists do to you
jesus just uh poked around i had to do
x-rays
oh it kind of hurts i actually have a
really really
bad gag reflex and um a strong gag
have a strong gag reflex and so when
they when he was moving the thing around
with the x-rays i
vomited a little you did i did in your
mouth nope
so you vomited outside of your mouth it
went oop i caught it
was he were you embarrassed yep but he
but he just kept going
he's like yeah that happens he just gave
us paper towels and oh my god i've never
done that before yeah
i grew up in your hand i come so close
every time and today it actually
ryan threw up in his hand folks i threw
up in my hand please give him [ __ ] you
could
reach him on twitter instagram all that
stuff
guys thank you for uh supporting the
podcast thank you for listening the
handles are at insideepodcast on
instagram and
uh facebook at insideepod on twitter
uh please subscribe uh it really helps
and if you write a review it really
helps a lot and i hope you spread the
word
as much as you can all right now it's
time that at the end of every show i
read
uh the top tier patrons
so these guys are on patreon patreon.com
inside of you these are the top tiers
they they give the most and uh i read
their names off and
uh ryan has memorized quite a few of
them here we go nancy
d leah
w robert uh abby
jason w
uh emily s yes cj p
and jennifer and stacy
uh h l l carly
carly h jen uh s
jamal f i i i i'm amazed
i'm remembering the ones that come after
before yeah weird
janelle b carey um
washington no kerry b kerry b
tabitha 272 not to be easy to tap into
73.
kimberly l e e mike
uh e eldon supremo
99 more ra mira
santiago f
m m sarah v f f
chad uh w leanne p
janine um you're pretty amazing
i don't know janine janine r ray a maya
p mattie s shannon d
matt w belinda and kevin v james r
chris h dave h samantha s spider-man
chase sheila g
brad d ray h t tom n suzanne b
liliana a michelle k hannah b michael s
talia m betsy declare m liz j laura l
chad l rachel or michelle nathan e
marion megkay janelle p trav l dan and
diane r oh uh audrey ah jetta oh jetta
lorraine g
veronica k big stevie w kendall t carol
d
then we got sandy b angel m eric c
rhiannon c
stephen m cory k super sam emily c
sherry s coleman g dev
nixon michelle a liz l jeremy c
andy t cody r chris e sebastian k
gavinator and h
elliott m john b brandy d avoir
and bonyo orbano
b-a-n-o b-a-n-o isn't that bonyo
there's no tilde over the end no that
would be bathroom then wouldn't it that
would be bad so it has to be bono
bono bano conveniently is it bano guys
bano uh thank you for listening it's
always a treat having you here
and um it means the world to me that you
guys continue to listen
and hopefully you'll continue to listen
uh
from michael rosenbaum here in the
hollywood hills uh i'm also ryan
taylor's
saying goodbye on that camera right up
there ryan let me just give a little
wave and uh
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of each and every one of you i hope you
have a wonderful week
and spread the word